And again, if you think of a program as a succession of states that passing assertion
can immediately tell you that there is large parts of the state
where the infection cannot have taken place.
If these were the time object in your state, you would know that all of them have correct values
because none of their assertions has failed.
One problem, however, remains without time class.
You can still pass floating point numbers as arguments here
and then get an error while we're trying to print the time.
So here is your programming exercise, extend the code such that all parameters up here
are automatically converted into integers.